c'est un exercice imposé depuis la mise
en place de la collectivité
chaque conseiller exécutif il va de ses
arguments pour défendre son bilan un
bilan chiffré par exemple quelques 367
millions d'euros ont été investis dans
le secteur de la santé et du social
c'est un tiers du budget de la
collectivité autre priorité
l'utilisation des fonds européens et cet
argument avancé il objectifs chiffrés
qui avait été initié en touche été
atteint et dépassé il y à 2288 dossier
qui en est ainsi décidé au titre des
fonds européens et je la vends présente
une mobilisation de 481 millions de
fonds communautaires changement a permis
de mobiliser d'autres montants ou quand
l'investissement correspondant joie de 1
milliard deux cent trente millions il
s'agissait par ailleurs de rappeler les
chantiers en cours comme celui de la
cité scolaire la grossière de sainte
marie où des projets agricoles de pêche
et d'économie avec la création de fonds
de près aux entrepreneurs des avancées
pour également réduire la fracture
numérique et la facture énergétique
et puis cette volonté de poursuivre
l'intégration de la martinique à
l'international 8e showman chefs d'état
que l'association des états
la caille au jour là par mark hamill 19
cas pas longtemps côté bande nicaragua
pouvoir chez la question de la
collectivité aerial maritime et
numérique de leur territoire
un bilan et des faits marquants en 2019
le drapeau et l'hymne volonté de la
majorité de la ctm ont largement fait
polémique
alors ya les gentils blancs et
imaginables déroulé et rival chez soi à
noter l'absence de claude lise
représenté par le vice président de
l'assemblée
yan monplaisir
[Applaudissements]